this week on brian ross investigates
millions around the world watch the
video but no one paid more attention
than ira tolls i texted my sister and
said to my sister i think that's the guy
that shot me community activist michelle
gross
also was quick to recognize the officer
nearly on george floyd's neck
i saw him i said i think that's derek
chauvin oh no
despite a long record of brutality
complaints derek chauvin was still on
the job
had even received a medal of valor this
was the
um the logical and sad outcome
of allowing officers to act with
impunity
plus a full year now since the coven 19
pandemic
afflicted the world dr william shafner
came on our program to warn back then
of what was to come next big surge that
i anticipate
will come in the late fall and early
winter we'll check in tonight to see
what the next year holds
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors
of media about how dark your baby is
going to be
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined tonight by my
colleague as always rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with the trial of
the minneapolis police officer
accused in the murder of george floyd
his name is derek shovin and as the jury
will learn whenever it is seated
he is an officer who has faced brutality
complaints again
and again from people who had the
misfortune of running up against him
rhonda
that's right derek chovin has a long
history of police brutality complaints
but has faced very few consequences so
far
so perhaps it was no surprise that a lot
of people recognized him
in that notorious video that was shown
around the world
clearest picture yet of what led up to
the deadly confrontation
in the death of george floyd the unarmed
black man in minneapolis who died in
police custody
he can be heard on the video saying i
can't breathe what became
some of george floyd's final moments and
again
a warning some of what you're about to
see may be considered graphic
of the millions of people who watch the
george floyd video
i cannot breathe no one was paying more
attention to the actions of officer
derek chauvin
than ira tolls i texted my sister and
said to my sister i think that's the guy
that shot me indeed it was
tolls had been shot seven years earlier
by officer chauvin
as he and other officers responded to a
domestic dispute
all i know is he kicked down my front
door
i ran into the bathroom he kicked in the
bathroom door
i stood up and then he just started
hitting me after he started hitting me
i got shot and he tried to walk him
through the apartment
and i couldn't walk anymore he later
claimed you were trying to go
for his gun yeah yeah
i read that when i was i did a couple
days in jail because they dropped the
charges
but um yeah i found out that uh
he said that i tried to take his gun
from him
was that true hell no no
no and tols was far from the only person
to recognize officer chauvin in the
video
i saw him i said i think that's derek
chauvin oh no
but then i heard somebody in the video
shout out a badge number
bro 1087 bro
you're a bum bro so i pulled up my badge
number list of minneapolis police
and confirmed that that was in fact eric
chauvin
michelle gross is the founder and
president of the minneapolis group
called
community action against police
brutality she was not surprised to see
derek chauvin using
a long band technique to hold george
floyd on the ground
well it wasn't a surprise because i knew
of him because he was a bad actor for a
long time
he has been a problem officer for a very
long time and so his name was well known
to us
and minneapolis police department
records show officer chauvin
was the subject of at least 18
complaints involving
police brutality along with other
internal investigations
in all but a few cases no action was
taken against him
it said to me that um all the times that
people had complained about his conduct
and that he had been given a free pass
this was the culmination of that you
know it's what you see when there are no
consequences for bad conduct
and we have a real problem in
minneapolis because we don't hold police
accountable
and again this was the um the logical
and sad outcome
of allowing officers to act with
impunity
ira tolls never filed a formal complaint
against chauvin
after he was shot by him i tried to but
back then we didn't have google and
computers and smartphones like we did
i had a blackberry at the time and it
was not that good but
uh yeah so i didn't know what to do i
was 21 years old
um i did try to seek legal aid but
i was going to the wrong type of
defenders so i didn't know there was a
difference
and tolls has since learned that chauvin
was given the department's medal of
valor
for his handling of the incident are you
angry about all this
i'm very angry i'm very angry
i'm angry at the whole system um
and angry that he didn't have to
announce himself
uh give me any commands tell me any tell
me to get on the ground
uh he just started hitting me and then
shot me
that's what i'm mad about i'm mad that
he's able to do
that and get away with it and then
get a promotion or get a award
tolles who has since been convicted of
at least two felonies
involving domestic abuse says the
initial incident with chauvin
led him down a bad path
for you what will be justice in this
case
um i'm a god-fearing man i believe in
forgiveness and stuff like that but
also believe in accountability
everything i did in my life i had to
be accountable for so he has to be
accountable for it also
prosecutors say they intend to call as
witnesses at least two people who say
chauvin used the same
knee-to-neck technique on them in
previous years
new first-hand accounts that former
officer derek shovin
who was seen with his knee on floyd's
neck for more than eight minutes
had acted with that same kind of force
before for michelle gross
justice will mean more than just a day
of reckoning for
derrick shelton so i say indict convict
send that killer to jail the whole damn
system
is guilty as hell the reality is that we
have a lot of officers that engage in
similar conduct
and have had no consequences whatsoever
including officers who have killed
people
and so um you know our city has made not
one single change
to address our policing problem since
george floyd was killed
and the same goes frankly with our state
legislature you plan to closely follow
the trial
without question um i it will if we have
have a prosecution in this case a
successful prosecution rather
we it will be again only the second time
a police officer has been successfully
prosecuted for killing a member of the
community
and it'll be the first time that a white
officer has so
we are watching this closely michelle
gross thank you so much for being with
us here tonight
thank you again for having me we're
joined now by chief
mitchell davis of hazelcrest illinois a
board member of the national
organization of black law enforcement
executives
and chief as you see the reports there
from minneapolis the question is
accountability
not just for this one officer but for
the department he had so many complaints
against him but no real action taken
yes sir um you know it's systemic so
that that's what it goes to show is that
there's challenges
from the top down that need to be
addressed and
it's within the culture of the police
department and uh you know
when officers uh are subjected to
to folks claiming that there's things
that they've done they need to be
properly investigated
uh there needs to be due process for the
officers absolutely
but there needs to be some
accountability and systems have to be in
place to allow that process to be played
out
so that true a true finding or true
meaning happens at the end of everything
this must be so troubling for members of
your organization the black
uh police the law enforcement executives
when you see this you know what's going
on and you see nothing happening
how troubling is that for you
well police officers in general but
especially
uh black police officers we we bring a
different lens and it's
it's not that our lens is is better it's
just different it's just a different
vantage point because most of us
have had uh personal experiences
obviously not to that extreme but most
of us have had our own personal
experiences
as it relates to law enforcement you
know i think i might have mentioned it
before when i was here that my two worst
experiences
with law enforcement were both when i
was police officers
and in both instances they knew i was a
police officer and it stopped nothing
as far as what they were doing as far as
disrespecting me and violating my rights
chief davis a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
chief davis you've been a chief and
you're in a lot of different
organizations at
high levels what can be done what are
the next steps there's obviously
tremendous community
unrest about this but from the law
enforcement officers
what what is being discussed about how
to what to go how to go forward
so there's a lot of fear in law
enforcement now
um you know and it's kind of getting
it's giving me a different viewpoint of
of my profession and folks that are in
my profession
in that there's a lot of people that
that say that they want
change they want to make things better
but when actually there's time to
implement change
some folks are reluctant you know change
is uncomfortable and growth is
uncomfortable
and oftentimes in law enforcement
especially when that change is being
demanded from the community
it really makes law enforcement
uncomfortable and with that being said
it just makes it scary for a lot of
folks what we as
as black law enforcement executives uh
once again our personal experiences
tell us that you know these things are
real they've happened to us they happen
to people that we know
and you know we're not talking about 50
years ago we're talking about things
that happen
now and they and they happen to us in
spite of who we are
so we understand and we know that they
do happen in the community in general
chief with all that have you ever
thought about just throwing up your
hands and giving up going into a
different
line of work you know what that would be
the easy way out
um but uh you know i'm i'm a man that
of god and i believe that uh this is my
ministry
you know i believe god has put me in
this place to tell my story and to share
my experiences
to help to to move things forward uh you
know
often folks think that because
when they hit a word reform to people
talk about reform
often in law enforcement it's often seen
as people don't like the police
folks in high crime communities people
of color
we want they want the police in the
community they want us there but they
want good policing done they don't want
policing at any cost
they want good policing and good
officers there so
reform is not a bad thing reform by
definition has changed for the better
and it's it's not a bad thing and that's
what law enforcement needs to realize
that we've got to come together
and make positive change and move
forward so that we serve those folks
that are asking for our service
properly all right chief mitchell davis
from the black
organization of black law enforcement
executives thank you so much for being
here tonight we appreciate it very much
thank you sir
coming up next one year since the
pandemic lockdown
hit this country we're joined by dr
william shafter
one of the country's leading experts on
infectious disease with what to look
forward for the next year
you're watching brian ross investigates
the law on crime trial network
with millions of americans now getting
their covet 19 vaccinations
it's a sign of real hope and optimism
celebrated around the world and across
the country
including by dolly parton who before
getting her shot
broke into song vaccine vaccine
vaccine vaccine i'm begging of you
please don't hesitate
vaccine vaccine vaccine vaccine
cause once you're dead then that's a bit
too late
we're joined now by dr william shaffner
and dr schaffner she actually got her
shot from one of your colleagues at
vanderbilt
brian that's exactly right she's
absolutely charming and she was
wonderfully
on message she did get her vaccine
recently right here at vanderbilt
we were proud to give it to her and we
want everyone else to listen to her
message
get the vaccine when it's your turn roll
up that sleeve
we're making progress
what's next for this year do you think
doctor
well uh next year has its uncertainties
but there is light at the end of the
tunnel that's getting brighter
we are getting vaccinated more more
and more
and do you see stumbling blocks ahead
though with those yeah
do you see stumbling blocks ahead dr
schaffner
yeah my concern of course are two things
one is
that there are a fair number of people
out there who are still very hesitant
to get their vaccines so we need to
reassure them
and many of those people are members of
our minority communities
our ethnic communities so we need to
reach out to them
because they've been hesitant and of
course the other thing is the virus
those variants are we going to have new
variants
that evade our our vaccines protection
hasn't happened yet but we've got our
eye on that
and what's your concern there because
you really know about this these
variants do occur right
it's kind of a race to get vaccinated
before that happens
we want to get as many people vaccinated
as quickly as possible
you know the variants occur when the
virus
mutates and the virus mutates when it
multiplies
it gets into a new person and begins to
multiply
that gives it an opportunity to create
mutations
that result in variance we want to
reduce the
opportunities for the virus to multiply
let's all get vaccinated
as quickly as possible and then cases
will go down
and i think those variants will go to
the side
you are one of the first on this program
to predict that surge we saw in the fall
and the winter
is there another surge coming do you
think is that likely or possible
well it's interesting you ask right at
this time because
there are a number of states that have
removed the mask mandates
and we have spring break lots of young
people getting together for prolonged
periods of time
they could spread the virus among them
go back to their homes
and set up little mini outbreaks all
across the country
i hope that won't happen but it's the
sort of thing we need to avoid for a
while
we need to keep being careful while
we're vaccinating
you saw president biden refer to those
who took the mask
off and changed the regulations listed
them as neanderthals would you agree
with that
well i wouldn't do that but wearing a
mask
is inexpensive it's easy and it's
wonderfully effective that ought to be
the last thing
we take away while we open up our
commerce
our entertainment our culture carefully
please
all right dr william schaffner from
vanderbilt university
one of the country's top experts on
infectious disease always great to have
you on the program for the last year
thank you so much again for being here
tonight
good to be with you brian
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite about oprah
and her great interview
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
back now with this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite
and we're joined now by the
editor-in-chief of meteorite aidan
mclaughlin
meteorite which like the law and crime
trial network is part of the dan abrams
media company
naden we begin with your winner oprah
winfrey for her bombshell interview
with harry and megan on cbs 17 million
viewers
and headlines around the world
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what and
who who is having that conversation
with aiden the washington post the
columbus margaret sullivan called oprah
the greatest celebrity interview
ever what do you make of that
i saw yeah and she said uh it could be
the best interview since frost nixon
um which is i mean oprah winfrey is
getting high plotted for
this interview um it was a pretty
spectacular one it lasted two hours
uh it was a special that aired on cbs as
you said it got 17 million viewers
um which is you know perhaps not as
large as i guess some of the
trump interviews that we've had in
recent years but is the biggest audience
for an entertainment broadcast that
we've had
since last year's academy awards as cbs
probably boasted
in a press release today um and i think
it's with good reason oprah
had a series of incredibly impressive
moments throughout the two-hour special
she asked the right questions and then
followed up
directly and elicited a number of
newsworthy moments
including meghan markle revealing that
she had suicidal
thoughts um and as well as you know the
good thing about this oprah interview is
that when she asked these questions
she really followed up to elicit more
information out of them i loved at one
point when prince harry said that he
felt trapped within the royal family
and she said you know tell me how a
literal prince born into privilege
felt trapped um and it really got the
heck desire to open up
um so i think it was a very impressive
interview and she's clearly getting
plotted for it and she's a celebrity
herself doing
an interview with two celebrities uh was
it easy for her do you think or
our challenges here well you know i
think oprah is one of those
uh celebrities that you know she's known
on a on a first name basis
um which i think probably helps her a
significant amount you know i i would be
a little bit more nervous probably going
into an interview with
meghan markle and prince harry um she
lives right down the road from them
that probably helps with uh with
interviewing them but
still you know there have been a lot of
celebrity interviews recently done by
people like oprah
this one was really really stood out and
is you know getting even sort of cynics
like
uh margaret sullivan of washington post
to declare it one of the best celebrity
interviews of all time
all right and quickly this week's loser
tell me who that
is kaylee mcenany just signed up as a
contributor for fox news
now he had initially uh signed up for
fox news
as a contributor in january but they
then denied
uh that she was signing on and said that
they actually had pushed
uh the discussions they were having with
her uh presumably in light of the
attack on the capital that her boss
president donald trump
had inspired so she eventually fox news
announced that she had joined the fox
family
after initially having denied hired her
hiring her the fact remains that she
spent
uh weeks on fox pushing the uh fantasy
that trump actually won the election
um which is certainly not a good look
for uh the network
um hiring someone you know it's a news
network and they're hiring someone who's
known for pushing
a lie uh so i i don't think a good uh
start for kaylee mcinnini in her media
career
absolutely not all right aidan
mclaughlin editor-in-chief of mediaite
thank you so much
for winners and losers and thanks to all
of you for joining us here on brian ross
investigates
we'll see you again next week and thanks
to the great team getting us on the air
and off the air so successfully
[Music]
[Applause]
you